brexit was is and remains an idea about
the British Parliament taking back
control of the agenda setting its own
laws and making its own rules so what to
make of the decision by the new Prime
Minister to block it from sitting at all
for a five-week period at the most
crucial moments in the entire process
with one eye on a very possible national
election Boris Johnson insists it's
about setting out his new government's
plans and that MPs are not being frozen
out of having their say over brexit
there will be ample time on both sides
of that crucial October the 17th summit
ample time in Parliament for MPs
to debate the EU to play brexit and all
the other issues ample time but those
MPs who have vowed to do anything in
their power to block and No Deal brexit
who've even threatened to set up an
alternative Parliament's if their views
are ignored described the Johnson move
as nothing short of a constitutional
outrage a step on the road to
dictatorship it is a constitutional
outrage this is an attempt by a prime
minister who was elected by a very small
number of people in the country as serve
tea party membership to ride roughshod
over Parliament and prevent any
legislation or debate that would stop
this country leaving the EU without a
deal and all the problems that it will
cause he seems to want to run headlong
into the arms of Donald Trump
more determination than I've ever seen
anyone else before this is extraordinary
Johnson had been thought to have been
getting on better with European leaders
of late and hope had not been lost among
them that some new deal could be found
but time is now extremely short and
there's a genuine sense of crisis among
those who fear the hardest of Breck's
it's the great conundrum of a brexit has
always been whether it should simply
fall to governments who execute the will
of the people or whether
parliamentarians should have some kind
of final say to determine what sort of
brexit they think people actually voted
for by taking MPs out of play at such a
crucial time Johnson is effectively
testing whether they have the will the
resolve to try to overthrow him his
government and potentially the
referendum results as well that attempts
will now probably come sooner rather
than later national elections will
almost certainly follow something surely
must happen now to resolve this sense of
democratic crisis in the UK